pour les étrangers les étrangers c'est
nous eux ils nous voient comme nous ne
pourrons jamais nous voir
avant de venir en france il nous
imaginaient bien sûr maintenant ils sont
là ils nous côtoient alors non non non
non je n'ai pas été déçu physiquement
vous trouvez oui oui oui mais même plus
mais ils sont particulièrement bons par
rapport aux autorisations de ribéry
particulièrement bons en français cette
fois ça de jeu point fait c'est pas
tellement quand c'est plutôt petit tout
cas toujours non plus c'est cette
manière assez facile de dupont percée de
physiquement il est pas très sportif je
crois que que
hulot il a parlé paris l'a pas il n'est
pas bien fois je crois il fait pas de
sport il ya toujours à ces gens qui qui
m'ont dit que les garçons français n'est
est pas bien matt il est bon c'est pas
vrai les oublis non c'est pas vrai tout
ce trou qui sont très bien lorsque je
vois un français je saurais dire si
c'est un français ou un américain par
exemple je serai liés par la façon dans
le fossé et marche commentée du mans il
est un peu raide je trouve par rapport à
l'américain qui est un peu dégingandé
chez l'américain par exemple l'amérique
est toujours très dégradé je trouve et
rien que de dos je vous dirais entre
deux personnes celui là est français et
l'autre et d'amérique qu'est ce que
c'est le français thibault s'est séparé
c'est grand c'est grâce et il y a
toujours bien français des petits peu de
ces gars aux gens comment ça peut être
des gens pour la borne wi les biens
français c'est des petits il est né à
montpellier hérault taille 1 mètre 80
cheveux châtains foncés vieux noisette
signe particulier un peu raide dans son
attitude
jean paul laborde qui ad'ailleurs
l'assistant de l'émission est donc pour
sandra l'étudiant français qui est fille
est la fille la jeune fille
5 milliards mais la génération d'un
petit petit son petit impair
semblant de bruit sur un homme est
toujours en charge et couleur blonde
vous aimez ça qu'on change les couleurs
oui je préfère les brillantes et vous
ben je trouve que la question c'est très
difficile à répondre parce que on part
toujours d'un point de lui de son pays
ou d'un idéal et je trouve qu'en france
beaucoup de fils un peu disproportionné
c'est à dire ou trop petit ou trop
grands n'ont pas tremblé ou alors j'ai
pas c'est pas la forme par exemple que
je pourrais trouver dans un livre oui
elles n'ont pas de forme idéale pas de
forme idéale elle est pas spécialement
joli c'est vrai elle est parce qu c'est
le manger mais elle sait très bien
s'arranger
elle le sait trouver la chose qu'il y va
et en général elle elle est très
mignonne jolie et le sait c'est une
chose et il ne faut pas aller à une
studios de télévision de dollars d'aidé
cinéma vous pourrez garder ça on peut
les garder un marché toujours dans la
rue ou de l'université
entré chez les ont des yeux très belle
vous pouvez dire beaucoup
quand vous regardez dans les yeux ça
c'est une caractère dont réponse est
pratiquement il ya il n'y a pas d'homme
tout le monde
des filles comme ça avec les yeux comme
ça quand on garde les yeux d'une
française vous pouvez vous pouvez les
yeux de mme française parle
repartant dans leur pays ils emporteront
deux ou trois images
celle-ci peut-être elles changent elles
existent elles n'existent pas la jeune
fille française
est-ce que c'est elle je trouve que la
française est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus réservé beaucoup plus retirés
enfermé qu'on le pense à l'étranger à
l'étranger si on se fait une idée de la
française d'après ce qu'on peut voir
dans la dans les films français d'après
je ne sais pas brigitte bardot une autre
actrice alors que j'avais l'impression
que la française est très très retirer
qu'il est difficile d'établir surtout
pour un étranger en contact avec une
française mais me contactent des zones
d'étudiants si vous voulez la
compréhension de la française envers
l'étranger
je trouve qu'elle est lé plus souligné
qu' entre le français et le manger moi
c'est parce que vous êtes un garçon
c'est peut-être possible c'était
possible mais je trouve j'ai vu ça dans
les discussions mais j'ai aussi vu que
par exemple désert des français qui
sortait avec des français avec des
filles étrangères
ils ont bien des discussions mais la
discussion se termine si tôt possible
pour aller danser alors que les
étudiantes françaises
john's aime bien discuter par exemple on
peut passer une soirée entière avec une
française en discutant dans un café en
ait l'impression d'avoir vraiment passé
une telle soirée
vous avez bien le français mais j'aime
bien vous en épouse auriez une n'ont
jamais pourquoi parce que je crois et
les trop libre c'est à dire je crois que
nous manu c'est celle des chefs de la
maison c'est l'homme et moi je me
dispute souvent avec mes amis avec les
vieux aussi jeudi à l'ats c'est ce n'est
possible une femme n'a pas de toit de
faire ça et c'est vrai c'est pourquoi on
a pas mal le même toit
con comme comme le mari par exemple et
au fond cela peut être vrai oui
peut-être
c'est vrai mais moi j'ai trouvé les
produits pro ou voulais que ce soit
l'homme qui commandent fin n'ont pas
commandé alors ça je ne vais pas dire
mais quand même l'ombre est long pour
moi j'aime beaucoup mieux les français
pensent que les français oui oui aux
questions d'un pour les questions n'ont
pas manqué son caractère mais je trouve
les français un peu trop ce que nous
appelons dans langage assez crus des
étudiants baratineur oui et je suis
toujours très gêné quand il commence à
me plaire à ti n'est pas la peine ne
baratine pas je sais comment sont les
français
oui mais alors qu'est ce qui se passe
une fois que vous ont pas
ça marchait bien on devient camarades
dans mon camarade si tous ne faut pas ce
qu'il sait faire
la technique du baratin est valable au
bistrot à la sortie des cours n'importe
les deux secrets sont le hasard et le
plus tôt il faut un coeur léger point
d'amertume un peu de naïveté hausse mais
ça il est rare que les étrangers s'en
rendre compte
ils sont très gentils ils jouent aux
dettes ils vous aideront toujours quand
vous voulez savoir quelque chose
si vous voulez avoir dû contacter mon
vécu sur dans leur vie familiale dans
leur vie privée
c'est très difficile et c'est exactement
quand vous parlez contre mûrissent terme
immédiatement si vous voyez la chaîne
dans la rue à l'origine non je ne vais
pas dire mal élevés mais disent que vous
pensez elles n'ont mal élevés c'est trop
dur ça mais alors ils sont comme on dit
il s'en fiche de tout et ça fout tout et
ils n'ont pas tellement gentil tellement
poli mais on peut dire impoli un petit
peu oui mais ils ne savent pas d'autre
chose
alors j'ai vu notifier par exemple clé
qui est l'effet de trier et qui mettait
en valeur souligne qui est encore à
table alors sous la table gaccio mais il
se fait alors ils mangent avec en mains
sous la table et pas avec le couturier
fourchette alors passé ils ne ferment
ils ne ferment pas ne sert même pas
leurs beaux charmants jamais alors vous
pouvez entendre qu ils mangèrent police
croire on n'a pas le respecte avant le
professeur comme en allemagne par
exemple on discute avec les professeurs
ça je trouvais une chose impossible
on peut on peut parler avec les
professeurs mais pâtira c'est impossible
cette chose c'est pas vrai et c'est
traître c'est mais vous pensez que ça
nuit à leurs études en définitive demain
vous pensez que c'est mauvais pour leurs
études en définitive c'est louis un lien
de discuter tous les ans de oui j'y
crois parce que sage
on ne va pas seulement à l'école aussi à
la maison dans les familles que je
connais et ne pas respecte et ça je
trouve c'est une chose qu'il faut
d'avoir ils ne sont pas tellement
disciplinés oui je justement cet aspect
taquin frondeurs la fois sceptique par
un an et cynique si vous voulez c'est ça
que khimki
c'est par ci par ses traits là que je
crois que je qualifierais un étudiant
français l'étudiant français c'est à
dire il faut il faut le connaître il
faut connaître et je trouve que pour le
connaître cela c'est difficile
enfin les français ne se lit pas très
très facilement
ce n'est pas par antipathie ou quelque
chose comme ça seulement
très souvent ils sont en petit groupe
très très souvent mes pensées les
français oui et c'était assez difficile
d'entrer dans un de ces groupes
cette pompe est difficile découper les
gels ce tir est le meilleur qu'il ya
entre et nous les étrangers et les
livres les étudiants de français je vais
dans un club je suis un trajet je vais
demander à une française vous pourrez
danser du no mercy elle danse avec ses
amis je n'ai pas des amis français parce
que je ne le trouve pas ils sont
très différent de brésiliens font pas
veut pas ne crie pas bien les étrangers
ils sont pas sympathiques avec les
étrangers je trouve qu'ils sont très
secs très fermé des amis je ne pas
connaître et d autres sont pas gentils
base et mac
nous aussi sur nous même nous aurions eu
beaucoup à dire mais nous n'avions pas
le droit de répliquer cette image du
français nous pouvons la trouvais
désagréable conventionnelles pour la
changer
il existe un bon moyen c'est que nous en
imposerons une autre
[Musique]